great to have you here Mike great to be
with you Dan story line of the Super
Bowl
today is what nothing it's boring it's a
patriot so half of the Super Bowl is
gonna give us nothing all week I mean
you know we've got the predictable
what's Roger Goodell gonna do if he has
to hand the trophy over to Tom Brady and
it even gets more awkward the next day
cuz they have the day after press
conference for the MVP if he wins the
MVP that's when he directly hands him a
trophy if it comes to that but I don't
know that yeah well we're getting ahead
of ourselves I think the Falcons get a
little upset when we talk about these
hypotheticals of the Commissioner giving
the trophy to Tom Brady because that
presumes that the Patriots will win if
I'm a falcon I I hope all the attention
goes to the Patriots now I know what
happens it'll be nobody gave us a chance
Oh what was me everybody thinks the
Patriots are going to win but if I'm a
falcon knowing how these weeks go in the
thirty Super Bowls that I've been around
move in in your own direction without
any interruption and don't crave
attention and it's a team that doesn't
crave attention but there's gonna be a
couple of guys they're gonna be asking
for a little attention this way it's
amazing when you think about how this
team has been one of the most dynamic
dynamic offenses we've ever seen and we
never talk about them we don't take them
seriously all year long and it's the
perfect sweet spot for Dan Quinn because
on one hand it doesn't have to worry
about anybody getting complacent and
then on the other hand you can use that
to put a chip on everyone's shoulder as
the Super Bowl approaches because hey
nobody believes in this nobody talks
about it and it's a great situation for
him and you and you wonder about this
everybody's gonna say Patriots because
of the experience because of Tom Brady
because of Bill Belichick but you know
we've seen these games where it's like a
changing of the guard and I feel like
that if this goes the Falcons way that's
what we're gonna be saying a week from
now we should have seen this coming
the Falcons are the new team that is
going to be asserting itself year in and
year out so hey I can't get a feel for
which way this game is gonna go but
you're right the Falcons have to love
the fact that they're being overlooked
right now yes they can't they can't kind
of fight it and say wait what about us
because that's when it gets dangerous
because the media is looking for
something and if you give them something
you're gonna get a whole lot of
something so you have to be careful with
that but we also have the the role that
politics could play in media night
tonight with Donald
Trump with Tom Brady Bill Belichick
Robert Kraft now Robert Kraft's not
going to be there to be interviewed but
Belichick and Brady are how much of a
role does that play in non-traditional
sports outlets who were gonna cover
media night well they may they may try
to ask questions but in Bill Belichick
and Tom Brady we got two of the all-time
greats at deflecting just I got nothing
to say about that you move on to the
next question
and especially Belichick he just say I'm
not gonna talk about that let's talk
about football I'm here to talk about
football ask me football questions I
answer them and Ike Brady's already
tried to avoid talking about Donald
Trump and I think if anything this week
they'll be even more determined to avoid
giving anyone a sound bite that takes on
a life of its own
the thing I always worry about is not
the one person who is you're gonna ask
or should answer its teammates who have
to answer for somebody that's where it
gets a little dangerous because now
somebody's gonna say you know do you
support Brady's supporting Donald Trump
now you may get a storyline here and
whether it is or not you could get that
this week it's an election of robots if
you know I mean that's the problem
they never say anything even remotely
interesting even Rob Gronkowski he knows
where the line is and he stays away from
it so I think they're all gonna be
prepped they're all gonna be properly
advised on what they can and can't say
and nobody's gonna step over that line
what if Brady showed up with a Donald
Trump paddle you know dummy just say
Here I am
I was thinking we should have hats made
make that say make football night in
America great again shouldn't we have
that no we don't need to because it
sorry it already is that's right was
this a good year for the end of him well
it didn't start off very well I mean
when you have primetime ratings 25%
lower than they were the year before in
these apples-to-apples comparisons I
mean that's concerning now after the
election it turned around and I think
the playoffs one of the circumstances
were pretty good because we had one good
playoff game but the ratings were
roughly on par with what they were a
year ago so I think it's turning around
I think next year has the potential to
be really good that because they're
going to be comparing next year's ends
to this past year which wasn't very good
so hey we're up 10% this year yeah in
comparison to last year which wasn't any
good well how important is having a good
Super Bowl here to sort of
the exclamation point instead of a
period at the end of this season I think
it helps but you know the NFL grew and
grew and grew all those years where the
Super Bowl wasn't very good you know
we've gotten sport and reseed years were
more often that's good but I remember a
lot about Super Bowls in the 70s and the
80s but the sport still kept growing and
growing and growing when did I change
when when we started to have more
competitive Super Bowls in Y well I
don't know I'm ever Super Bowl 25 the
the bills in the Giants that was one
that we didn't expect to be competitive
yeah and then Super Bowl 36 it seems
like that when the Rams Patriots was the
was like this new age of good Super
Bowls even though Tampa and Oakland was
not a good one it's like every year
after that the default is and I think
part of it is now that when a team falls
behind seven or ten points they it used
to be except for the 20 to Washington
and Denver when Washington came back
down ten nothing used to be if you were
down seven to ten points that was it you
were broken the stress this stage
everything caused you to crumble now I
think a team falls behind it doesn't
give up like the Patriots two years ago
they're not ten points in the fourth
quarter they come back and win the game
that used to be unheard of if you were
down by one or two scores in the
seventies eighties that was it it was
over did Roger Goodell have a good year
oh I don't know it's not over yet very
bad on Sunday night and Monday morning I
think I think that any time but it's
about content though you're gonna have
good content though if he has to hand a
trophy to Tom Brady oh yeah I mean I
don't know if it was a good year a bad
year for him there's been worse years
right last year with all the deflategate
stuff and I just feels like it was just
a year he didn't really stand out one
way or the other which I guess you would
call a good year if the the Commissioner
isn't a major storyline like it was with
Ray Rice or deflategate then he's just
there then I think it's a good year he's
Mike Florio from pro football TOCOM
joining us Dan Patrick show John Lynch
is the GM of the 49ers maybe I shouldn't
withdraw my name from consideration like
I don't know if anybody saw that coming
yeah and here's what happened they went
into the process intent on hiring a
general manager they really wanted Chris
Ballard who's now the Indianapolis
general manager but he wasn't interested
they wanted NICUs area they want to do a
package deal Nick Caesarea from the
Patriots with Josh McDonald that didn't
work out and what happen
was two weeks ago they got to a point
where Kyle Shanahan was the only
coaching candidate left that was it so
he was in a position to ask for all
sorts of stuff and he's going to get I
think thirty million over six years he's
gonna have full control over the roster
and once it became clear that he's
running the show
that's when Lynch approached him because
Lynch isn't gonna be running the show in
San Francisco it's gonna be Kyle
Shanahan but Lynch is gonna be the guy
in the front office who's pulling it all
together and it just kind of worked out
that way but who who knew he tell you
what for a team that has been notorious
for its leaks in recent years you know
nobody knew anything about John Lynch
being interested in this job or them
being interested in him so I guess it's
a good litmus test for whether or not
they've plugged their leaks now moving
forward we'll see if they can win some
football game studies is this a
ceremonial role here because he's not
running the show as the GM well but you
know he's gonna be running the front
office and I think their intent on
having a good partnership between the
coach in the GM they had the Jim
Harbaugh and Trent Baalke thing which
was a disaster they really want to have
a good relationship between coach and GM
and even though Kyle Shanahan is gonna
have final say
I think Lynch is gonna be the guy who
pulls it all together kinda like John
Elway did I mean this can go one way the
other it's gonna go John Elway or Matt
Millen no and you know Matt Millen a lot
more parallels to John Lynch but you
look at our way that the Denver pedigree
and the thinking is Lynch is always a
guy who's over achieved he's gonna work
hard he's gonna come in he's gonna do
all the right things and as long as
people around him that he can trust and
you pull it all together you have a
consensus everyone's on the same page I
mean they can't ever to a14
the barceló so they can go four and
twelve next year and double their wins
200 you know a hundred percent
improvement and we still stink but you
know we're moving on the right direction
do you went in on our bet on
McLovin at the end of last year said
deshaun Watson was going to be the
number one player taken in the draft so
this is last year the Joe Thomas came on
our show and said you know we should not
take a quarterback here but McLovin has
a wheel of punishment bet on deshaun
Watson it's the number one overall pick
now it doesn't have to be the Browns it
could be if somebody trades up or
whatever but is deshaun Watson the
number one player take what more can the
guy do a lot of how everybody gets upset
because he can go to the senior bone
just put in the tape he faced the
closest thing college football has to an
NFL defense two straight
in the national championship the biggest
stage in college football and he
shredded them one year they didn't win
one year they did win that should be all
he needs to do and if you're looking for
somebody who's gonna thrive in a big
stage and thrive the next level I don't
know why the Shawn Watson wouldn't be
the guy now I'm not ready to sign on for
anything that's gonna have me on the
wheel but I mean I don't know why I
don't know why it's not and I don't know
why it wouldn't be and you're gonna hear
all these different names and you know
what it's like before the draft and it's
all this misinformation and nobody wants
anyone to really know what a team is
thinking and for the Browns what they
want to do is trade down and then say
that the guy they took at five six seven
eight is the guy they would have taken
at number one so you never say who you
want so you can always say that after
the fact but I don't know why you
wouldn't want the Shawn Watson yeah Dabo
Swinney last week said he's Michael
Jordan so you know good enough for me
do you believe that no you can't have 11
guys on the field I I wasn't sure what
he meant by that because I thought it
was unfair to deshaun Watson to say you
know this is I mean Michael became the
greatest player of all time and you know
Houston got the guy they wanted a team
Elijah on it was Portland who took Sam
Bowie so that was it was one team who
passed up on Michael Jordan maybe it was
Michael B Jordan he meant that he's
gonna be the next Michael B Jordan
here's the bottom line though you need a
franchise quarterback if you have a
franchise quarterback you're gonna be a
contender you're an in year out from 10
to 15 years and there's only one
reliable place to find one it's at the
top of the draft once-in-a-lifetime
you're gonna have a Tom Brady in the
sixth round are you gonna get a Tony
Romo or Kurt Warner undrafted that does
not happen very often you get that high
draft pick and now especially since you
don't have to make that huge financial
investment like it used to be it's worth
taking a shot I don't know why the
Browns wouldn't take a shot they got to
stop that you wonder how many names are
on that jersey now it's like 28 names on
the jersey of starting quarterback since
in 1999 they desperately want to find a
guy that's gonna be their guy for 10 or
15 years would you take - Sean wants it
I look you don't want me running your
team but yeah I'd take me well you can't
do any worse than the Browns have but
when you see what he did it's Nick
saving defense okay
I just don't want to end up on this
wheel of punishment I think Mike needs
to be punished Minh no mokou fix him
then yeah
McLovin a kicker if it's him McLovin
it's your wheel to punishment well he
just said the Browns might trade down
and take him at five do I get out then
what wouldn't be him I mean they could
say they can take somebody else at five
and say that's the guy we would have
taken whoever is the the team that takes
that has the first pick is your wheel of
punishment if DeSean Watson's name is
not called the first name then you get
wheel to punishment okay how about first
pick and second round out no no no it's
one thing it's one overall that's it two
spins wheel of punishment how about Mike
my kids Stan spending time with me no I
can't
yeah why why is there friction between
you J I don't know it's we started off
joking around at some point it just
became real yeah but what happened you
know Mike guests hosted and during the
look ins you know on the basketball
court there are a lot of elbows things
got kind of serious I get back home you
know I get a day off and then I come in
and in McLovin goes not good with Florio
and I go why what happened we just don't
get along and I said well he was
threatening you not get along with
Florian he was throwing a football and a
look-in I'm like Mike have you
considered that maybe you're not a lefty
and you're really arriving to break the
ice
yes boy I don't want to stoke this up
any further but Perloff technique I am
me a little bit ago you guys you guys
are you looking at the monitor I think
my hair looks just as good as Florio's
no you need to get picker glass here we
go I is there jealousy on your apartment
Clubman because you there was a long
time ago before Mike really took off
yeah McLovin had a problem that he
thought you two were equal in covering
the NFL 2003 and yes and then all of a
sudden you you know you he would come in
and go Florio got a TV gig do you see
that I go yeah what happened you
finished a distant second to Florio you
were gonna be who we were gonna hire on
NBC it was you or Floria
and I voted for Florio yeah so blaming
Mike it's great to see great to be you
know you in the club and have a great
week together he's Mike Florio from Pro
Football Talk on NBC Sports radio's 6:00
to 9:00 a.m. Eastern weekdays thank you
Mike
thank you the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]